[Music]
hey where's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome back we had a little bit of a
break fair a lot has happened since that
K 20 Pro video a week and a half ago
number one we've finished shooting retro
Tech season one so it's now in the
editing process which is really exciting
and number two the channel just rolled
over nine million subscribers which is
incredible so thumbs up for that
and number three Samsung just got on
stage and unveiled their two new phones
Samsung Galaxy Note 10 and Galaxy Note
10.1 en't but if you don't want to watch
all of that this video is for you
I got hands-on time with Samsung's two
new galaxy notes and I have some
thoughts so first of all the Galaxy Note
has always been Samsung's do everything
maximum overkill phone for power users
you know but now that there's two phones
I've kind of found there's this
interesting relationship between the two
where the note 10 plus is still the
do-everything phone with one exception
but then the note 10 is a sort of
awesome phone for most people type of
phone I'll show you what I mean so the
new design first of all I really like it
they're leaning into this boxy look the
display goes right up to the edges
there's almost no top or bottom bezel at
all and the screen has this curve on
both of the sides that really make it
feel like almost entirely screen it's
super immersive especially the corners
it gets crazy close to the corners and
doesn't round them too much so I love
the way this phone looks and feels in
the hand as cliche as that sounds but
even though I kind of like the flat
screens more this is a nice phone design
it's a 6.3 inch 1080p AMOLED display on
the note 10 and a six point eight inch
1440p AMOLED on the note 10 plus and so
now there's a couple of things to note
that actually happened with the note
here the selfie camera is now in the
infinity o cutout meaning it's the hole
punch in the middle of the top of the
phone mixed feelings on this but I don't
hate it it's a smaller area than it was
in the corner of the s10 and there's
usually no information in the middle of
the top anyway so I guess it's fine and
it's also kind of funny they didn't even
really
try to hide the cutout at all you see a
lot of phones with the hole punches try
to like hide the cutout with a nice
gradient wallpaper so you don't really
notice it but not with the note this is
uh this is the default samsung wallpaper
bright as hell just embracing it I guess
there's also a new set of colors one of
which is this crazy psychedelic rainbow
sheen that they call aura glow it's kind
of wild how many different colors you
see in it but also still a fingerprint
magnet and will probably still be worth
skinning or casing but this color is
crazy cool and the fingerprint reader to
note has moved quietly underneath the
display glass to match the Galaxy S ten
but it's not all amazing there are some
things that they've changed that aren't
so great there is no headphone jack on
the samsung galaxy note the first
Samsung flagship really with no jack
they say it's an issue with space for a
bigger battery I say like if you can fit
an entire pen in the side of the phone
you could have fit a headphone jack this
is no longer a space issue in the phone
guys this is a constant choice that
they're making if you haven't already
noticed it's the beginning of the end
the headphone jack is its leaving and
it's not coming back Samsung will
include headphones but USB type-c
earbuds in the box and no dongle
included so if you still really want to
use that Jack then you're on your own
and they also mess with the button
layout so the power button on the note
10 is now also the Bigsby button did you
not think I was gonna bring that up
Samsung so on the left hand side it's
just the button and the volume rockers
so the whole other right side of the
phone is just clean it's blank no
buttons at all and so that power button
if you just tap it it does the normal
wake and sleep stuff but if you hold it
for any longer bixby no matter how long
you hold it this button does not turn
off the phone it will just open Bixby to
turn off the phone you'll have to go to
this new button in the notification drop
down right next to the Settings button
and that'll let you decide to turn off
your Note 10 I didn't get to spend
enough time to see if this was
remappable in the settings or if you
could disable it I'm hoping yes but
that's something I'll have to figure out
when I actually get the phone for the
full review so definitely stay tuned for
that
though honestly note 10 and note 10 plus
are built awesome
they're premium they're metal and glass
it's what you'd expect and then also
there's a camera upgrade so you've
probably noticed already by now the
triple cameras on the back there's a 12
megapixel main camera a 2x telephoto
camera and an ultra-wide as well which
is sick and when showing me this phone
Samsung is making a big deal out of how
these new cameras are great as a pro
photo and video tool so I did notice you
can record video with the ultra wide
camera again so you can get that crazy
GoPro look with this water-resistant
phone but they also added features like
live focus during video recording an
improved super study shot for video so
the stabilization is awesome and this
crazy zoom in mic feature which
basically is the more you zoom in the
video the more the microphone array
focuses on the area in the frame like a
sort of a spy kid's gadget from 2001 I
definitely got to try this out in a
controlled environment also shout out to
mr. Mobile's cameraman for going the
extra mile can't wait to see that shot
in his video but then of course it's not
a galaxy note without the s-pen and
they've refreshed the s-pen again this
year with a couple extra new features
screen off memo has been one of my
favorite note features for a while now
but something they added in the notes is
they convert your handwriting to text in
the background and then indexes that
text so now if you take a note with the
stylus and then want to find it later
you can go up into the search in the
Notes app and type the word you wrote
and it'll actually show up that is a
super cool I think a very useful feature
there's also now some new air actions
for controlling the camera like holding
the button and swiping between modes or
flipping from the selfie camera to the
back camera or allegedly even twirling
clockwise or counterclockwise to zoom
but I must have been doing this wrong I
honestly couldn't get it to work for the
life of me you probably need an S Pen
twirling tutorial that I'm just not
ready for file these in the gimmicks
folder please but around that one you
eye on these Samsung phones is
definitely going to help on the bigger
screens because of all the improvements
to the one handedness and there's even a
couple extra new features like a native
screen recorder too on the Galaxy Note
but
overall yeah it'll look similar to the
galaxy s 10 as you can already see with
the flatter colorful look we've seen for
a while now that's just one UI oh and of
course how could I forget
the specs it is a flagship after all
boom
you're looking at pretty much all
top-of-the-line and a 25 watt fast
charger that comes in the box which is
great and a really solid battery on that
note 10 Plus look the note 10 and 10
plus are looking like pretty great
phones but there's something I want you
to notice if you've paid attention
throughout this video you've probably
noticed there's a bunch of little things
that are different between the 10 and 10
plus that push you towards the 10 plus
and by you I mean the power user you
know of course the larger screen and
larger battery that's obvious with the
bigger phone but also the note 10 is
1080p and the note 10 plus is 1440p
there are three standard colors but
there's an extra fourth fancy blue color
just for the note 10 plus there's going
to be a 5g version of the note lunching
later this year and it will only be 5g
for the note 10 plus you max out at 8
gigs of ram on the 10 or you can get 12
gigs of ram on the 10 plus there is 256
gigs of storage on the 10 or up to 512
gigs of storage on the 10 plus and the
microSD card expansion slot is only on
the 10 plus and then on top of that the
10 plus is the only one that supports
the crazy 45 watt super fast charging
the brick is sold separately but that
would be some crazy fast charging to be
able to use that even with the three
cameras they both have triple cameras
but if you look closely the 10 has just
the three cameras and a flash while the
10 plus has a bunch of additional depth
sensors for good measure
now does all this somehow mean the note
10 is bad or lacking
no it's still 8 gigs of ram and 256 gigs
of storage and the snapdragon 855 and
400 PPI even though it's 1080p is still
great it's more than most people alive
need right now but it's those extra
little things on top of all of that
especially the battery that big battery
that make the note 10 plus the king of
the hill the flagship that they want
your power users to go out and spend
extra on so the note 10 starts at 949
bucks and the note 10 plus starts at
1099 that's the gap but here's my take
I'm gonna review both so I'm gonna go
get them both in hand I think this might
be the first time I actually really like
the smaller phone as far as feel in the
hand over the bigger one I think we'll
see and honestly the one thing I wish
they did that they didn't with the note
if they really wanted it to make the
everything phone for 2019 is a high
refresh display you know a 90 Hertz or
even 120 Hertz display that's not
happening
still with 60 Hertz OLED and it's still
of course one of the best screens in any
phone but it's gonna be hard to say that
this phone does everything when you're
starting to get phones even though it's
pretty new like the 1 plus 7 pro and the
ROG phone doing crazy numbers but anyway
that's been it I've been talking for too
long it's a long video but that's
everything you need to know about Note
10 and Note 10 plus feel free to share
this with anyone who might be
considering getting one and that's been
it for my first impressions thank you
for watching catch you guys in the next
one
pace